Royals in quarantine wow what a car exit
last night Harry showed up on the BBC to
celebrate veterans it's the sixth time
he's made an on-camera appearance since
the lockdown began and we can't forget
this video which Harry himself shot in
honor of Archie's first birthday
see that Archie flick Club sticker the
book was a gift from Oprah we've seen a
flurry of activity from Prince Harry
Harry and Meghan obviously you needed
some time to settle into their new lives
I'm told that they feel a great sense of
freedom and they're enjoying being able
to do things a bit more on their terms
back in the UK Harry's 94 year old
grandmother remains in isolation at
Windsor Castle with 98 year-old Prince
Phillip there's been speculation the
Queen will step down from her royal
duties and Charles and Williams stepping
up indefinitely never give up never
despair well palace sources are very
keen to play down rumors of the Queen
stepping down retiring and even scaling
back but the reality is is that we have
seen Prince Charles and the Cambridge's
stepping up to the plate more now than
ever before William and Kate are not
just zooming they really put their kids
out there actually during this pandemic
we'll see more of the Royal children and
I can get any other point I mean the
Queen cannot go on forever and I think
what we really are seeing is what the
future is going to look like our house
the new protocol seems to be more
lighthearted and fun even Kate's brother
James Milton got into the act shaving
the beard he's had for the past seven
years and sharing the quarantine
makeover on Instagram there we go
[Music]